all right welcome to GCP online Meetup
number 32 I'm Jonathan Kim
I'm your host today today we have a very
special guest Priyanka vergata how are
you I'm good
yeah and one thing I just found out
you've only been here for what three
months Wow I know you're the expert at
chat box there's a fist pump right here
that's good that's that's really
impressive
so yeah Priyanka has been around you
know for only a couple months but she's
been telling us all about chatbots and
how chat bots have been proving and
automating a lot of the you know a lot
of the activities for her customers so
yeah tell us a little more yeah sure so
um I am customer and engineer here at
Google so just a little introduction
about myself I do have some background
in IVRS and technologies like
interactive voice response and that's
why chat bots do you said in my have a
special place in my heart so as soon as
I joined Google I realized that we
acquired this company called API Road AI
which we have renamed to dialogue flow
now and I got my hands around it and my
customers were talking about how we can
improve their experience so I just got
hands down working on some customer use
cases and I realized six this could be
very helpful to do as a as a live
session for some of our online folks as
well
so that's where that that's why we're
doing this today please do send us
questions so we can answer them as they
come in yeah so we'll be answering your
questions and just one thing that
Priyanka mentioned is about the user
experience I've actually worked with a
lot of customers who say I mean they
want to you know attend to customer
needs very quickly right I think we're
living in a digital age where we expect
the answer is right away like hey we
know what's my shipping confirmation you
know where's my flight status they want
it right now and chatbots will be able
to give you that kind of immediate and
you know the sense of urgency that
customers desire and want and also to
extend to that point a lot of my
customers like help just everybody in
every customer can relate to because
everyone has a helpdesk and everyone
gets those calls around how to hardware
reset my password or how do I submit a
ticket and they don't want to talk to
anybody so from the user perspective
they don't want to talk
to anybody and from the company's
perspective they don't want to raise
money on handling those types of Monroe
and his calls so I think for those
reasons as well chatbot is very good
yeah
if someone had to talk to me about
resetting passwords every time exactly
yeah that's a good segue into kind of
what you're demoing which is a ticketing
system yep all right so let's just dive
right in
I have I don't have a lot of slides all
I have is to show you a demo and then
how that demo actually works behind the
scenes so that's all that's in the
agenda and then you're obviously always
welcome to post questions we'll handle
them as they come in and also towards
the end so without further ado let's get
into the demo so this is that help desk
demo that I was talking about you could
you could put your you could actually
integrate it with your web chat
interface or your mobile website
interface I'll put it in there you could
also put it in your in Google home as an
app as an action and then you can also
use the same chat bar that you built in
dialogue flow and put it into your
assistant as well so it's like one-time
effort but you can broadly distribute it
if you into all the different channels
you could use Facebook as well for if
you interface with your customers or
work so just for some of the viewers so
that they don't feel intimidated I mean
you don't actually have to do any
machine learning like I mean you're not
doing any like mathematical algorithms
and things like that for you to do this
I'm glad you asked that question no
you're not so and I'm going to show you
in dialogue flow it automatically learns
so all you're doing is basically
providing it a couple of different
utterances were of what a user can say
and then the machine the software would
basically learn on its own over time as
to what rikku requests it gets and then
it it modifies itself over time
there is also a training component to it
so you can train it with the requests
and responses that you could get great I
guess we'll walk through that in a
little bit yep all right so let's try to
test this thing I would like to submit
ticket and then it should respond back
saying alright give me your name so I
can put you put your ticket in and then
I can say I'm just making up some name
and then it will say okay thank you John
so it it's smart enough to understand
that this was John and then now describe
the ticket for me and then I can say
write my phone screen is broken even
that and then it should respond back
saying I have logged your ticket in this
is their ticket number and someone will
contact you in 24 hours and that's all
you pretty much need in most cases like
a person on the phone would also just
call in and submit a ticket for you and
they won't be personally handling the
ticket right somebody else in the queue
will be handling the ticket so the chat
bot just did that in like five seconds
for for the customer now you take that
now you can see what happens behind the
scenes so I have a data store behind the
scenes which is a database no sequel
database and it's basically sending that
data into the database and saving it so
my phone screen is broken this is John
this was the ticket number what is it
using to send into data started so it
uses cloud functions to send it to data
store and in cloud functions and I have
it up here it's really not a big code
that you're right now all you're doing
is just interfacing with datastore and
calling the API for the datastore so
right here I'm taking and parsing out
that email phone number if you're not
catching the email in this case because
they use it and give it to us if they
did we would catch that as well but you
take that put it in the datastore and
then respond back saying I successfully
launched your ticket with the ticket
number so it's very simple function that
you're writing and the reason I'm using
cloud function here is also because you
don't have to set up servers or install
them and do all that jazz all you're
doing is you just need a function that
can talk to an API right so that a cloud
functions is best for doing that so
alright we did that in the chat you
could do the same with Google home or
action so let me just give you a little
glimpse of how you would do that with
with Google
I'm using the simulator which you would
use to test out and I can say talk to
help desk support let's get the test
version of help help me reset my
password
no problem and be your username and I
will send the link to reset your
password
alright so that was what I wanted to
show you like you could do the same
thing that you were doing from the
interface from chat also within within
Google home now how was all this built
so let's get into your dialogue flow a
little bit to understand how this was
all failure as I'm sure you want to know
that as well so I'm gonna talk about in
intense and entities in a little bit
more detail I have a slide in there but
it's basically insured intent is
basically whatever the user can say and
then what do you do after user says that
so like what action do you take and what
response do you provide the user that's
an intent and entity is B so I'm gonna
open one of the intents here so that you
can see so we you saw that we submitted
a ticket so that's the intent where user
can say I want to submit a ticket I have
a problem I have an issue they can say
all sorts of things to submit a ticket
so now you're capturing them in a bucket
that these are all the things that a
user can say and then you're taking an
action on it so in this case I don't
have an entity because all I want is to
capture those those things that the
users saying the problem the incident
the ticket and then just give them a
static response which is okay sure I can
help you with that give me your name
so there's no action that I need to take
other than just giving them a static
response so that's why this one's a
little bit simple when we go into this
one which is the description so remember
when I asked for the description from
the user like what is your what is the
problem that you're facing they said my
phone screen is broken my laptops frozen
or something like that
I am parsing out what type of a problem
is and that is just by nothing but
defining an entity and that entity in
this case is an incident type which I'm
parsing out and putting in my data store
and saying okay this is these are all
the tickets that came for phone problems
and so now I can say this is my entity
which is incident type and now it's my
variable that I can take an action on
and then I'm not risk
finding anything here but I'm asking it
to go to a web hook which is where cloud
function is written so when I go into my
fulfilment which is where are my web
book is defined this is the URL for the
cloud function that we saw right here if
I close that you can see that that's the
link to the cloud function and that's
what you define in your fulfilment you
could actually also write the same cloud
function within the editor and we've
just released this two weeks ago so
that's a really cool feature now you
don't even have to go out of dialog flow
to write a cloud function you can just
do it right here in the editor yeah
that's really nice so yeah that's that's
how this was all built do you have any
more questions yeah I mean I think one
thing to keep in mind is that you've put
in a lot of different intents right but
but you don't actually have to put every
single combination or permutation of
questions that the users gonna ask right
I mean that's the whole point of
training so can you talk a little bit
about the whole training process you
know you've collected maybe some
questions
that you get and you know at some point
maybe the chat bot didn't understand and
at that point you need to throw that in
there say hey this is you know the
intent is the same which is what you're
trying to do but they asked it in a
different way yeah exactly so really
glad you asked this is in this is the
part feature in within dialogue flow
that's in beta right now which is
training so the first thing you would do
for any machine learning models is you
would try to give it as much training
data as possible so that's what we are
trying to do with all the requests
utterances that we put in the intense
but there will be things that work that
you may not be able to catch in there
but those are the things that you can
catch in here on the screen I have the
training portion of the of the bar here
where if I click on one of these I can
see that help me reset my password was
correctly matched to an intent password
reset I could have found something that
did not match my intent so we could say
something and I can't think of an
example with wit but this could probably
imagine that this was attached to our
different or a wrong intent then we
could change that
right here and say
okay now attach it to contact us because
that's where it should fall and then say
that I approve that and then approve it
and once you do that now every time a
user says something related to research
or something related to help me reason
it would automatically fall into that
contact mm-hmm so that's how you would
continue to like somebody who's managing
this chat pod would continue to go in
and try to see if things are falling off
and then continue to maintain it and
manager by approving the training so the
chat pod captures all the history and
then can you show like how you actually
do training is that you just kind of you
have all this training data and then you
push the train button yeah let me do
this so let's see so I have CI say this
one and I change that and I change it to
I'm gonna keep it the same and just they
approve and then say approve and then
once it does that now see the training
is started it's starting to train and
you can see the gear icon moving here
and then once it's done it's going to
save the model astrayed and now it's
going to start and you can test it right
here as well you can test the same
phrase here it will start to take it
again very nice very nice and then can
you talk a little bit about the
different integrations that we have I
feel like dialogue flow one of the
benefits is there's a lot of different
integrations yeah so there is so the
point that I made earlier about I have
the web demo version and then I also
have the assistant that's enable so
you're basically building it once but
you can now deploy it by just toggling
the switch and say I wanted to apply
this on Facebook message messenger as
well and all you do is that and then you
verify your token for access to Facebook
and off you go and it's enabled for
Facebook as well and then similarly for
slack Twilio if you use Skype we have
some really cool integrations done with
Skype as well I think one of our
customers has used this for like
controlling their refrigerators oh wow
yeah it's a very cool use case and so
yeah you can these are all the options
that you can connect it
- and just write the code once that's
right so yeah that seems like it's part
of the fulfillment process you know you
covered intent and maybe at a high level
in tennis what are you trying to do
right like what's the goal maybe you
want to reset a password maybe you want
to order something maybe you want to
contact support talk a little bit about
the entities like how do entities fall
into the intent are they entities are
just things that you want dialogue flow
to capture from the sentence right right
so entities are think so let me actually
give you a simpler example so it makes a
little more sense so in this particular
example I have a weather forecasting
application right so this is much easier
to understand you say weather forecast
in San Francisco tomorrow so the user is
interested in San Francisco City and
tomorrow is the timeframe so those are
my two entities entities anything that
you want to take an action on so I want
to take an action on the city so I can
take the city and plug it into my API
and get a response for it so and then
same for tomorrow I can I could get a
request for today and then I would take
that parse it into a date and then give
it to my API and that would respond by
so anything you want to take an action
on the one thing I would also touch here
that you didn't ask gelatin is context a
context is very important as well so
this is this is actually a biggest
differentiator for for dialogue flow in
general so in this case I can say a user
can say weather forecast in San
Francisco tomorrow and then it would
respond back with that weather and then
following up I can say oh how about
today and then it would know that I'm
still talking about San Francisco so you
can set that context and the way you do
that is again going back into dialogue
flow and then I can show you one of the
intents that has context so when I'm
doing description remember it is it
remembers the name email and phone
number from my previous intent and all
you do is just connect them together and
it will remember the content
student so that was in short that's
really good so it seems like you can
make some very complex conversations
it's not just question answer question
answer it's more like question answer
follow-up question answer follow up even
more follow ups yeah and that's where
context comes in exactly and that's
where the whole natural language
processing within the within the engine
and the machine learning also comes into
picture as well so and it's learning
over time yeah that's really interesting
so let's see we have a couple questions
let's talk about all right what are some
drawbacks of you know I think you know
this is a meet up so we try to talk
about the great things about dialog flow
what are some drawbacks with dialog um I
would say it's a it's a product that's
obviously constantly evolving as we say
in machine learning is all constantly
obviously evolving and evolving so
that's one thing that I would say we are
very open to feedbacks and learning from
insults to a space that's evolving
itself in itself like Chad Watson yeah
so we are learning through the
experiences there some of the other
drawbacks I would say our religious
around like languages we're constantly
working on supporting more and more
languages I think we have about 12 to 14
today but like we have in the other
speech api's and we I think we have
around 100 hundred and 80 languages in
there right so around that range so
we're constantly trying to catch up with
that so that I would say is a little bit
of a drawback but other than that it's
evolving product yeah I mean I think so
customers obviously they love the fact
that it's out of the box I mean I'll
throw out some buzz words out there and
machine learning right like you know LST
M's recurrent neural networks I mean
these are all mathematical algorithms
and models used to build chat BOTS if
you're not interested in doing that
right this is kind of an out of box
solution if you need more control maybe
like let's say you're doing something
fun like I don't generating Game of
Thrones text or some like you know some
random language and you know that's
where you're not going
get that type of control with this right
this is you know we're training the
model for you we've built it out for you
and we've made it really simple but if
you need kind of variant specific use
cases yeah you know this is probably not
the best tool yeah I would also add like
you know if you're looking for trying to
find ways to start using machine
learning in some way within your
organization this would probably be your
good entry point to make exposure to
machine learning because it's like that
easy way where you don't have to worry
about training the model you still
understand how the model would be
trained if you do it with some other
application so I think it's like a low
barrier to entry into machine learning
in a way safe place because you you have
the model being trained by the platform
itself but you're just learning through
it right right now actually another
interesting use case that I've been
working with the customer on is you know
they see it as a phase approach right
machine learning is a very it can
encompass many things where hey we want
to automate everything we do yeah but I
think realistically it's just kind of
taking it step by step so the first step
is really let's just try to have a chat
bot right this is like a really easy
first okay let's just start figuring out
what customers are asking now that they
collected all this information they
might realize oh this is exactly what we
need or it's not yeah
and so it's like it's making easy step
back as well and if it's not then let's
just step back start again yeah you
didn't lose anything so yeah yeah you're
still acting all that you know data from
your customers into to build your own
model I mean we have customers building
no chat BOTS with our cloud ml
technology and yeah it's you know using
tensorflow
so it's a I mean there's many ways to
kind of do the same thing but yeah yeah
it's a platform to make things simple
alright so another question is it free I
love that question it's free it is
absolutely free at this time so you can
go ahead start building things and start
using them the integrations that you do
with your web hooks and stuff they could
probably cost you something if your
hosting them say you can talk functions
or some right actually that's where you
might get tired like cloud functions you
pay yeah it's small prices I'm a data
store you would pay yeah the right now I
think dialogue flow is actually free so
itself is free okay that makes sense
that's good
and then why why did Google rename ATP
III I mean like when I first heard of a
pasa I don't know what it is most people
thought that right like what is API that
AI you get a website okay is it a chat
pod okay so this chat pod is that all it
does because if yet is such a broad name
right great question yeah and you you
pretty much kind of answered your
yourself it's basically it was hard to
understand what it was just fight the
name and it is API it's in his AI but
again in normal language its what is it
really doing it's really helping you
have smart and intelligent conversations
which is very much aligned with the
dialogue flow name yeah that's why we we
took a step back and we made it more
commonly use of your word then than epi
da da which is hard to comprehend as to
what it does
I think the funny thing about names is
no one's ever gonna agree on a name like
I mean I love flow you can argue yeah
it's not the best name but it's not the
worst right I think for any name it's
it's always gonna be a yeah you know
argue arguing there'll be some in
support and some yeah yeah just like
politics so alright know that that's
good out and then I think so
met a questions linked to dialogue flow
dots and intro I haven't heard of it
before yeah so Alex will definitely send
a link to actually if you just do a
quick Google search hopefully Google is
good at finding done I think I did a
quick search yesterday and its first
thing that comes in okay and then Ashok
asked the question how to name an agent
for different integrations or is it the
same for Google home and Alexa it's the
same for everything so all the
integrations you have you will name the
agent the same so there there's only
going to be one agent and then the
integration you just enable the
integration
to be available for all the different
platforms but you're only writing the
agent one right so yeah very complex if
you have to create a different agent for
different integration so yeah basically
one agent encompasses all the different
the different key points okay yeah great
and then let's see here
all right well look I don't see any more
I mean there's a lot of questions so I
think that's it you know definitely
subscribe to the channel if you have any
topics you'd like to discuss throw it in
the comments Priyanka thank you so much
for a time that was fascinating
I mean I'm gonna build a chat by just to
talk to me because I don't have many
friends you should do that but I can
talk to you alright
anyway thank you so much tune in next
time I think our next topic in two days
actually on terraform which is super
cool as well you know automating
deployments with terraform on Google
cloud platform and yeah all right thank
you very much thank you for having me
here
[Music]